[Music]
which
wow
that is spoopy kyle
this is security booth
where i'm guessing i am a security guard
in a security booth
ominous deep rumbles
that bodes well
oh
am i
oh there i am hello job rules
make sure to talk to the person in the
car they must work here check person's
license plate on the front of their car
if the person's license plate is on the
employee register let them in if they
are not on the register you must tell
them to leave only open the gate to
employees keep get closed until you've
checked the person's plate id
you go hey what's up man
hello
can i
great night we're having good things to
come i think mind letting me in
hang on i gotta check your plate g1269r
g1269r all right
g1260 to get the hell out of here oh no
stefan
all right step
all right stephan you're clear to go
have a good day stefan
you take care now
you dive safe you drive safe you drive
safe
all right you drive safe
all right well this is easy no one is on
the line
okay
well this job seems relatively simple
all i got to do is remember some numbers
can i help you
quiet nine but that's nice today just
feels like it's going to be hell let me
in
maybe leon31
we'll see leo we'll see
leo
leo i'm not seeing a leo
sorry pal you gotta get out of here
no i'm not letting you in
get out of here
you get out of here
well this job's pretty easy
it didn't even raise a fuss
you knew what you did oh god
i'm fine
everything's fine
hi
hi hey
what's up what's up hey how you doing
almost pulled a sick day but today is
just too important to miss let me know
when i can go in
yeah yeah you think i'd remember good
boy
it's a good boy is that a good boy
oh that's a good ball oh
oh oh
good boy george phillips hey georgie
hey georgie
it is an important day you get in there
you work hard you work diligently don't
cause any trouble and drive safe okay
all right
cool
sounds good why do i have this other
side
all right drive safe whatever the
important day it is
probably important
or something
anyway
well this is lovely
i do love my job
hi
nice shift again i hear that i doubt
tonight will drag on too much not for me
at least uh can i go in uh we'll see
about that uh x
xt2 m28
xd2
xd2m mario
hey mario you can go whoa you can go
right in buddy you can go right in all
right head in have a good day you take
care now hey we'll get some beers later
uh ignore the door that just came in
between us hey we'll get some beers
later hey hey mario mario
hey
ah we'll hang out later what's some of
these signs
say the excitement is a rush we are so
close to finishing the experiment we
have had a few accidents someone called
natasha died last week but it's all
worth it in my opinion some rando named
natasha died
hey who cares i think that was their
name hello
a friend
zero
five
four
seven
am i supposed to am i hero am i supposed
to remember that zero five zero four
seven seven
seven
oh
error code
zero
five
four
seven
okay
zero fifty but forty seven seven zero
zero fifty but forty seven seven
zero fifty
but forty seven seven
zero 050 477
hey what's up how you doing what did i
just see
rather be at home playing games but i
got called in for an emergency could you
let me in funny i didn't hear no no
au-8
ui
au 8 7 ui
hey ua ellen ellen
ellen hey y'all get the gate for you
ellen you have a good day now ellen that
emergency um uh
let me know if they need any security
i'm a very capable security guard
hey why don't we get some beers later
way hey hey ellen
helen
i'll get him next time
but forty seven seven
zero fifty
zero fifty oh
hi
i thought wait
can i help you
can i help you sir
hey sir you got a mosey hey i'll be
right with you i'll be right with you
i'll be right with you sir
another late night yeah same mind
letting me in yeah we'll see about that
yeah we'll see about that
five ah 48 fa 5
something 48.
okay ah andreas andreas yeah you go
right in you go right in andreas watch
out there's uh some characters here hey
buddy you gotta move it pal hey well you
can't be loitering or i'll warn you next
time
i can't come any closer
you better watch yourself pal
you watch yourself real good because i'm
watching you
i'm watching
you i'm watching you
do something
make a move
i dare you
that's what i thought
you coward
hey uh yeah you better run
yeah you better on you better watch out
there's an emergency here or there's
gonna be
if you try to make a move
scare them all right
who's there
don't think i'm afraid
because i'm not
oh well that can't be good
system failure
system failure uh huh
system failure sounds like you need the
help of a big strong security guard
okay
hey did you hear a kaboom
oh do you hear a weird rumble this is
nova nexus hq right today's my first day
and got a little lost and running late
mind letting me in
um i don't like the way your thing is
rumbling
de4 t93
e4
t93
the e4
e93
oh
sorry pal
you gots to go
[Music]
yeah you you better get out of here
you the same guy i saw before huh
you same guy
the same guy
yeah you better run
yeah you keep moving what is the
rumbling
[Music]
yeah science nerds
they're always working on something or
other oh hey
if the director keeps his running his
goddamn test will never get open
classified
hello
[Music]
hi
okay oh
high five bro
who the hell
do you think you are
as a security guard
i think this is highly irregular
oh another note
a
friend
i'll be right with you
the director's still running tests i'm
going to shoot him if it goes any on on
any longer all right well that's a bit
aggressive
hey what's up bow
ah
let me check your license
r8031
uh yeah what's up
[Music]
i can only help so many people at once i
am one security guard i will be right
with you oh
[Music]
emergency
lockdown system activated okay security
weapons activated oh oxygen levels
reducing oh your families will be
informed of your death oh emergency
emergency
lockdown system activated
security weapons activated
okay well
that's interesting
um
i don't know how the oxygen could reduce
outside so i'm probably fine finally the
experiment has been improved i'm so
excited i feel that classified will
really change this company in the world
for the better
people usually say that before
everything blows up
uh yeah what's up
can i help you pal i'm supposed to let
people in not out i'm supposed to let
people in
not out
oh my god okay geez yeah you can leave
whatever
yeah
yeah can i help you pal
what's up pal
you okay
hey
pending one
ending one
what do you mean ending one
what other ending would there be
that doesn't make the most sense but
okay
i didn't even know that there was
options
did i do something wrong
did i do something right
what happens if i just send everyone
home and i don't let anyone in maybe
that's one of the options
i guess what's to stop me from just
sending everyone away
i don't think that people should be
working today
i think that everyone should go home
stop right there pal
oh uh how about we go with a big old no
get out of here you stay back
you stay away
there's nothing good for you here
there's nothing for you
not here uh excuse me place is closed
place is closed get out of here no one's
allowed in
no one not on my watch
not on my watch what part of work
clothes don't you understand uh excuse
me almost pulled a sick day but today's
just too impr
yeah
can you uh get your ass out of my thank
you yeah today's not very important
you're gonna just have to leave
you're gonna have to go i'm probably
saving everyone's life
some kind of black mesa event is gonna
go on in there
i'm a hero what part of get out of here
don't you understand night shift again i
hear that
you're not gonna hear nothing you're
gonna go home a phony call
erico hero hero hero
same notes are appeared
no entry alert go home
hey welcome back you're not allowed in
either
no one is i don't think so get out of
here the stars are twinkling
that's incredible
i'm sorry you waiting for me to step in
the booth or something
oh you were
you were
hi
oh
[Music]
hmm
oh is this guy again
[Music]
uh-huh
hmm
i'm keeping an eye on you
[Music]
now gone again
okay well there's that car that wanted
to be let out
so what happens if i don't let you out
j-h-o-e-4-4
well hang on
j-h-o
[Music]
nina
sorry nina can't let you out i don't let
anyone in and i definitely don't let
anyone out
that's for damn sure
nina
you can honk all you want
ain't nobody gonna let you out
nina
nina it don't matter
it don't matter nina don't matter you do
whatever you want i ain't letting you
out
keep on can see if i care and or change
my mind which i won't
listen i'm security guard i maintain
security which means this gate stays
closed
can't have any security if you keep it
open all right fine shut up
i'm watching you i'll come talk to you
hey you listen to me
hey you listen to me right now you
listen to me number one number two
you listen to hey
okay i don't know how to get ending
number two and i wasted a lot of time
just going through everything again well
i don't know
but if you guys can find out
you guys can check it for yourself and
maybe you'll know how to get through the
security booth but i like that a lot i
like that it had some uh cool elements
to it i like being isolated in a box and
having things happen to me um
but there wasn't a lot of actually
stuff happening you know there was a lot
of like noises and random spooks and
random things like knocking on the
windows and stuff but at the end of the
day that wasn't really something
happening so it would have been cool to
see like some kind of result but maybe
ending two has something more i don't
know but either way not bad link's in
the description if you want to play